pokemon big old pokemon news day we also
have a trailer for
horizon for ben west and we got like a
little playstation 5 thing
i'm current devina this is safe state 4
wednesday june 17th
welcome i snap
we're getting a new pokemon snap called
new pokemon snap like the og pokemon
snap from 1999 you'll be exploring
islands and taking pictures of pokemon
in their natural habitats where you'll
see
quote never before seen pokemon
expressions
and behaviors finally our very own
chastity can
stop taking pictures of her plushies and
act like it's
the real thing alright thank goodness
for her sake
here are my thoughts chastity but that's
not the only pokemon news we got today
we also got
pokemon smile which is an app that
encourages kids and you and adults too
to brush their teeth which i've needed
for weeks
[Music]
but that's not the only news that we got
today we also got a look at pokemon cafe
mix a puzzle game where
you run a cafe where the only clientele
are pokemon because i've wanted nothing
more
than a squirrel and a beret to complain
about me making their
latte too hot so anyways that's coming
to the nintendo switch and mobile
devices
in the fall and in case that wasn't
enough pokemon news we're also getting
another pokemon presents on
june 24th next week also
isle of armors is out the dlc for
pokemon sword shield so
pokemon we just got a trailer for
horizon forbidden west and
it's breaking down some of the game's
mechanics settings and some new features
that are coming to the series
the name forbidden west refers to a
frontier territory from utah to the
pacific ocean it has valleys deserts
ruined cities
and it's gonna have a bigger and deeper
map than the first game with
new underwater exploration the trailer
also emphasized that the game is really
going to take hold of the ps5
ssd saying it's going to virtually have
no
loading screens which is cool
so the game was revealed the ps5 reveal
event but
we don't actually know when it's going
to be coming out but it's aiming for
2021.
oh yeah and ps5 news because why not
so just for clarity this big chunker of
a
console can in fact lay on its side
and so uh here's an image of what it
looks like the digital edition next to
the disk drive one
okay enough of news really quick just
want to remind you that play for all is
happening it's a multi-week event that
we're doing here at gamespot every
single day we have charity streams from
12pm
to 2pm pt featuring a ton of special
guests raising
money for black lives matter and people
fighting on the front line for code with
19.
we're also having a bunch of exclusive
content and interviews
alongside that so be on the lookout and
just for a glimpse of what's coming this
week tomorrow on thursday we got jake
baldino and then on friday we got
joe zija a fire emblem actor hanging out
as well
so check that out full schedule that
everything is going to be in the
description below so
yeah all right that's it now there's
that and a whole bunch more on
gamespot.com so
of course go there to check it all out
and keep up to date on all the sweet
gaming news that happens because stuff's
happen
all the time constantly thanks for
joining me i'm curt davina
see you next time
[Music]
you